[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have revealed the
free games Pharaoh's PS plus essential
subscribers for the month of March 2023
almost an entire week earlier than usual
and like usual I'm here to break down
the games telling you what you need to
know what and all let's do this March
kicks off with Battlefield 2042 on both
the PS4 and PS5 the futuristic first
person shooter that allows 128 players
to do battle simultaneously in some of
the biggest Maps ever seen in the series
Battlefield is renowned for
destructibility making insane plays a
reality like breaking down a wall to
flank your enemies on release
Battlefield 2042 was well it was
terrible sadly it was a glorified beta
test thankfully every update since then
continues to improve the experience into
what we have today this includes the
return of the class system to allow you
and your squad to decide on roles within
the team and it also retains a
specialist system which gives us the
opportunity to pick a certain character
with unique abilities Battlefield has
more to offer than 128 player War zones
there are smaller versions of everything
to make strategy more important and
other game mods completely change things
up hazard zone is an extraction game
mode that asks you to venture into
combat to retrieve and recover gear and
then Get Out Alive kinda like modern
warfare's DMZ and probably the best
thing in Battlefield 2042 is Portal a
creative mode that lets players design
and create their own game modes
including content from older Battlefield
games like Bad Company 2 and 1942 you
should also know there is not a campaign
in Battlefield 2042. it's totally a
multiplayer focused Affair review scores
average out at about 6 out of 10. over
on the PS4 we have Minecraft dungeons a
Dungeon Crawler that's a spin-off
project with no focus on mining or
crafting Instead This is essentially an
accessible version of Diablo playable in
both single player or in a group of four
online or in couch Co-op too the dungeon
use procedural generation to create
unique paths which if all goes to plan
will mean playing the game a second time
will result in totally different dungeon
designs hopefully pushing replayability
in terms of gameplay and story The
Villain is Archie and illeger who stole
a MacGuffin of power and we simply have
to chase him down combat is both ranged
and up close depending on your playstyle
and that's where the real focus is
revealed loot everything is about Loot
and it's totally randomized defeater
boss open a chest get loot explore the
dungeons fully get more loot oh and
there's a level up system that lets you
add enchantments to your weapons to
upgrade them constantly if you've never
played a Dungeon Crawler before or
simply want more Minecraft lore in your
life Minecraft dungeons is a great
little game average score is 7.5 out of
10. finally we have code vein yet
another Dark Souls inspired action RPG
that does attempt to do something a
little bit different first of all we are
accompanied by an AI companion making
the entire experience feel less isolated
their bounty is also a great way to
remind players about objectives and
missions and the story and speaking of
the story we wake up in a new world and
realize we are actually an undead
Revenant who needs blood to survive
we're effectively a vampire summoned
back to life to fight off the monsters
in this world during The Good Old Fall
of humanity if you've played a from soft
game you know all the basic details here
timing and precision are needed in
battle and dying is an inevitability
another Soul's mechanic in code vein is
the ability to summon another real-life
player to help you with a tricky section
of the game code vein reviews equate to
a 6.5 out of 10. and before I go any PS
plus extra fam in the house Sony have
also teased five games coming in late
March ghost wire Tokyo Immortals Phoenix
Rising Tom Clancy's Rainbow Six
extraction the Uncharted Legacy of
Thieves collection and cheer which is
arriving day and date on its release but
let's put a pin in that until later in
the month I'm Adam you are awesome if
you got this far in the video please
leave a dab joke in the comments cheers